el cirujano llevará a cabo la reparación
del aneurisma aórtico abdominal para
prevenir la ruptura de un área
protuberante de la aorta la arteria más
extensa del cuerpo es la aorta la que se
encuentra adjunta al corazón y recibe
sangre directamente del ventrículo
izquierdo o la cámara de bombeo
principal la aorta se encuentra dividida
en cuatro partes aorta ascendiente arco
aórtico aorta torácica y aorta abdominal
la aorta abdominal es la última y más
extensa sección de la aorta
proporciona sangre a las regiones
inferiores del cuerpo entre ellas los
órganos del abdomen y la pelvis la aorta
abdominal finaliza alrededor del nivel
del ombligo donde se divide en dos
arterias ilíacas que transportan sangre
a las piernas la aorta tiene una pared
gruesa para poder resistir la alta
presión de la sangre que es bombeada
desde el corazón con el transcurso del
tiempo la pared de la aorta se puede
debilitar hinchándose lentamente hacia
afuera como un globo cuando esa afección
se produce en la región abdominal se la
llama aneurisma aórtico abdominal
el cirujano llevará a cabo una
reparación abierta del aneurisma aórtico
abdominal cuando el diámetro de la aorta
exceda las 2 pulgadas 5 centímetros o si
se presentan síntomas como dolor
abdominal intenso o pulso anormalmente
prominente del abdomen antes del
procedimiento abierto por medio de una
vía intravenosa se le comenzará a
administrar líquidos antibióticos que
anestesia una reparación quirúrgica
abierta tradicional sería con anestesia
general lo que significa que usted
estará dormido durante el procedimiento
se insertará un tubo respiratorio por la
boca y en la tráquea para ayudarlo a
respirar durante la operación cuando
esté dormido se le insertará un catéter
en la vejiga para drenar la orina y
controlar el funcionamiento de los
riñones el cirujano comenzará haciendo
una incisión desde el esternón hasta
debajo del ombligo luego ubicará el
aneurisma y bloqueara la arteria aorta
por arriba y por abajo
posteriormente el cirujano abrirá el
aneurisma
y ccoo será en su lugar un injerto
artificial con la misma forma y tamaño
de una aorta sana
el cirujano suturar a la pared del
aneurisma cerrado sobre el injerto
recientemente ubicado el injerto
reforzará las paredes de la aorta
el cirujano cerrará la incisión
abdominal con puntos la duración total
de este procedimiento por lo general es
de entre 4 y 6 horas el cirujano llevará
a cabo una reparación endovascular del
aneurisma un procedimiento más nuevo y
mínimamente invasivo si usted padece una
enfermedad cardíaca grave o presenta un
riesgo quirúrgico mayor debido a la edad
u otras afecciones médicas
antes del procedimiento endovascular al
igual que con el procedimiento abierto
una vía intravenosa comenzará a
administrarle líquidos y antibióticos
puede recibir anestesia general o un
sedante y una epidural o anestesia
regional para adormecer solamente la
parte inferior del cuerpo
el cirujano comenzará haciendo una
pequeña incisión en la ingle por encima
de la arteria femoral
luego insertar a un cable guía en la
arteria y lo empujará cuidadosamente
hacia el aneurisma
se pasará un catéter o tubo hueco sobre
el cable guía que será empujado hacia el
aneurisma
utilizando imágenes de rayos x en vivo
como guía el cirujano pasará un injerto
de stent endovascular un tubo comprimido
de tejido metálico a través del catéter
hacia el aneurisma luego abrirá el
injerto el que será sostenido en el
lugar con ganchos metálicos y stents el
cirujano puede insertar le componentes
adicionales del injerto para extender el
injerto en los vasos que suministran
sangre a las piernas
una vez que el injerto haya sido ubicado
la sangre fluirá por el mismo no
alrededor del saco del aneurisma lo que
quitará la presión del aneurisma
por último el cirujano quitará los
catéteres y cerrará las incisiones de la
ingle el procedimiento por lo general
llevará de entre dos y tres horas luego
del procedimiento si tuviera un tubo
respiratorio el mismo se quitará y usted
será llevado a la unidad de cuidado
intensivo para la recuperación recibirá
líquidos y alimentos vía intravenosa
es posible que también tenga un tubo
insertado en la nariz o en el estómago
para remover secreciones hasta que su
intestino recupere su funcionamiento
normal la estadía usual en el hospital
para un procedimiento abierto es entre 5
y 10 días mientras que para un
procedimiento endovascular por lo
general es más breve de entre 2 y 3 días